the Joe Rogan experience so when people
see someone like the proud boys running
around attacking people even the proud
boys you have to realize that they
started off as a joke like when Gavin
McGinnis first came up with the idea of
the proud boys it was it was literally a
joke and it became an actual
organization at for fun and then people
joined it that didn't think it was a
joke and then people joined and started
taking in a deeper in deeper direction
then he'll eventually disavowed himself
and then abandoned the group you see
that I beat I bet you see the same thing
with antifa
I bet the idea initially was hey we see
these tiki torch carrying [ __ ] in
Charlottesville we see that guy with the
car ran over the girl was a protester
and killed her like this [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's got to stop so we have to organize
we have to do something and then what
happens you get people in masks and you
get people justified and then you get
people that support those people and
then you get the extremists and the
extremists who are not disavowed or not
there's no one speaking out against them
from the left there's no one saying hey
this [ __ ] has got to stop because they
want them to do their dirty work for
them they want them to push the envelope
and push the agenda and get their D
their ideology moving in the right
direction even if it's done through
methods that they don't agree with and
that's where it gets horrible because I
see these people that are involved in
this and I know for a fact just by
watching them move and interact with
each other they don't understand
violence they don't they're not good at
it they don't understand it they this is
like role play
it's like cosplay and you're gonna call
for reach you're gonna get real violence
in return and from people who actually
know how to do it and if you look at
violence from the left and violence for
the right violence when the right scares
me a whole lot more they're a lot more
armed that it's it's they're more
dangerous human beings in general and I
think that if this this keeps happening
and people from the right feel
threatened and their lifestyle feels
threatened and their ideologies feel
threatened you're gonna get people
meeting at these things and it's going
to be more than just people throwing
mace and milkshakes at each other it's
going to be people showing up ready for
actual combat
that's [ __ ] terrifying it's [ __ ]
terrifying and this idea that you could
just run around
hitting people and not have any
consequences it's like the way a child
looks at violence this is what bothers
me so much if you are if you looked at
their core tenets of what they want to
do and if they wanted to accomplish that
through political negotiation and
through conversation and rallies and and
and speeches fine that's fine but when
you have people wearing masks hitting
and macing people you've you've Pat
you've crossed the line into the land of
no return and you've called out to
people who oppose you you've challenged
them to come and do the same and this is
how violence begets greater violence
it's [ __ ] dangerous it's really
dangerous violence does not exist in a
vacuum you can't just have a little bit
of violence and then there's no
repercussions people react to that
there's people that watch those videos
and watch you get punched and there is
no justification for that when you see
someone like yourself who's a small
person slight in stature not violent in
any way and you're not even swinging
back you're just taking it and trying to
protect yourself
people get infuriated by that and
there's people right now I guarantee you
who saw that video who were thinking
what I would do if I was there I'd
[ __ ] shoot all of them all right beat
them all to death with baseball bats or
I'd run them over with my car or I do
things and the unhinged amongst the
right who feel like this is a in
opposition of their ideology they're
gonna show up someday and when that
happens people are gonna die this is a
[ __ ] terrible and this is where the
mayor and the police and they have not
done their job and they're I believe the
police when they say that they've been
handcuffed and maybe the mayor just
didn't have an idea of where this would
all go but now you do this is the mayor
has been in office now for three years
and he finally did a press conference
two days ago nine days after my talk to
address this controversy right and what
was so frustrating is the the the police
chief had um publicly stated that she
thinks the city was a state should adopt
a law that makes it illegal to wear a
mask while committing a crime that
should be a no-brainer it's shocking
that in Portland I got a
better idea how about not you can't wear
a mask in public at these events because
you can say you can't wear a mask while
committing a crime you're wearing a mask
how do you who the [ __ ] do you know
committed the crime you unless you take
the mask off them you can't even
identify them it's stupid you can't wear
a mask yet so this you know sounds like
a baseline somebody policy that you
should start advocating right don't kick
babies
yeah well the mayor said he hasn't
decided if he supported it he hasn't
decided if he supported whether or not
should be illegal to wear a mask while
you're committing a crime right that's
hilarious and he had no policy proposals
and he spoke as if like it was his first
day in office when this was like this is
becoming routine now it's almost but now
in Portland in Portland is a harbinger
and a warning to what can happen in
other cities when you have a a
government those in the upper echelons
of governance turning a blind eye to
far-left militancy and just letting
these thugs go on the street just
imagining it was the case if they were
doing that about far-right militancy
imagine if there were far-right people
who are doing this and committing
violence and the government was just
like well you know I'm not sure if they
shouldn't be allowed to wear masks why
they commit crimes people would be
freaking the [ __ ] out it's the weird
justification of this stuff that's
that's so disturbing I just don't and I
[ __ ] love Portland so one of my
favorite places it's great the city's
great I mean it's [ __ ] cool people
it's not all of them that are involved
in this is a very small number and the
even amongst a small number it's the
very small number of them that are
radical that are violent when you look
at the people that are attacking you not
to minimize it but it's very few you
look at that video it's a couple people
out of thousands of people that are in
that group there's a few people that are
attacking it was about a dozen was it
really yes okay if you count throwing
milkshakes but actually hitting you how
many people you think hit you not sure
three four maybe something like that
okay that's the problem the problem is
these [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's not the people that disagree with
you the people that think you should be
able to throw milkshakes at people and
guys like Carlos Mesa who don't think
it's a big deal to throw milkshakes at
people it's a [ __ ] big deal it's a
big deal because you get calls for a
response this is why it's a big deal and
people don't understand assault
they don't understand violence you can't
just do that you live in some comic book
world or some [ __ ] Disney show world
where you can just throw a milkshake at
someone they don't do anything they're
gonna turn around punch you in your
[ __ ] face and then what happens well
you might fall and hit your head and die
cuz that's real that's the real world we
live in
or you might cause a giant brawl because
people don't want to be hit with
milkshakes or
there's enough of you where you think
you can get away with it so you're an
awful bully and you're throwing
milkshakes at someone because you don't
like what they stand for and you're
meeting in a public place and you're
disagreeing about something so - right
this disagreement you're assaulting
people well for that very reason and if
I never engages in like a canonical fair
fight one on one they're what they do
usually as a group while masked up one
or several of them will distract the
person either by speaking to them
perhaps or blinding them with the
chemical spray and then they take turns
the beating so there's even no
opportunity to like no you know you
don't even know how many people hitting
you at that point so that's what they do
blind you and then attack mmm it's so
it's so scary because it's so dumb it's
not just scary because like you watching
what happened to you scary cuz you know
and watching that old man who got hit in
the head with a crowbar
it's [ __ ] horrific all that stuff's
horrific apparently that guy had pulled
out some sort of a rod and was swinging
at people before if he got hit with a
crowbar I do not know but I do know when
you start hitting people in the head
with crowbars that is the beginning of
the end
horrible horrible [ __ ] happens in
response to that and it hasn't yet but
this is ten days ago who knows what's
going to happen if there's another one
of these rallies and you get people from
the far right who organized this is when
the proud boys really radicalized they
radicalized to go against antiva they
were attacked they attacked them and
then it became this [ __ ] [ __ ] show
that you're seeing right now
[Applause]